all right let's start at the beginning
it was announced today the Paul Manafort
well something that was pretty much
expected after his home was raided by
the FBI was indicted today it's a
31-page indictment it discussed charges
and will put it up on the side of the
screen for you money laundering failing
to register as a foreign agent tax
crimes but interestingly because this is
the special counsel that was supposed to
investigate Trump Russia collusion this
indictment has nothing
let me repeat nothing to do with Trump
Russia collusion zip zero nada the most
spectacular finding within the Manta
Ford indictment is this in regards to
the financial issues the last year of
any financial transaction was 2014 the
years they were looking at was between
2008 and 2014 and as far as we know
Trump was it even thinking of running
for president in 2014 so in other words
nothing of the Paul Manafort indictment
had anything to do with the Trump
campaign or Donald Trump is this all
Muller has because if it is it's
pathetic
another day another example after a year
of speculation no evidence of any
collusion between President Trump and
Russia now you've heard the saying
they've all heard it you can indict a
ham sandwich well grand juries are
convened guess what in case you don't
know only the prosecution gets to
present evidence the defense gets zero
opportunity whatsoever to present their
case the legal standard before a grand
jury is much lower
they must be convinced probable cause
okay but in a court of law
the criminal standard is a jury of your
peers beyond a reasonable doubt
a massive distinction and it's important
to point out that this grand jury was
impaneled in Washington DC let's see one
of the most liberal cities in America
were over 90% of the people there voted
for Hillary Clinton mr. Muller do you
think that's fair now here's what Paul
Manta Ford's attorney said earlier today
for the first time they speak out listen
the president Donald Trump was correct
there is no evidence that mr. Madoff or
or the Trump campaign colluded with the
Russian government today you see an
indictment brought
Office of Special Counsel that is using
a very novel theory to prosecute mr.
manna for regarding a Farah filing the
United States government has only used
that offense six times since 1966 it
only resulted in one conviction six
times since 1966 one conviction so like
every American Paul Manafort he deserves
what we all deserve the presumption of
innocence however he is being tried
tonight and convicted in the court of
public opinion by what is an abusive Lee
biased Trump aiding media also as part
of the news that came out today George
papadopolis he admitted okay he lied to
the FBI I think he's 29 years old now I
know everybody in the Trump campaign I
never heard about Papadopoulos until
today and I think I knew everybody now
the White House says he was a volunteer
and it seems that Papadopoulos on his
own was trying to create an anti Clinton
Russian dossier like the fusion GPS
Hillary DNC President Obama funded
dossier and he wasn't successful so now
that we have no Trump collusion here's
what we do have tonight this is what the
media will ignore this is what matters
these are the facts this is where the
evidence comes in what did help what did
President Clinton or President Clinton
wanna be President Obama and King
members of the administration what did
they know about the uranium one scandal
now we're learning about how the Obama
administration officials they knew in
2009 that Vladimir Putin was using
bribes extortion kickbacks money
laundering and racketeering all within
this country spies within this country
nothing was done to stop it
we have incontrovertible evidence that
all involved tried to cover this up
they put a gag order on the one FBI
informant that knew everything to
prevent the truth from getting out now
it's getting out we have
incontrovertible evidence that the
Clintons benefited in a massive huge
financial way because of this corrupt
uranium one deal we know Bill Clinton
double the speaking fees in Moscow
Moscow well given a speech to a bank
that interestingly enough had a
financial interest in uranium one
Clinton also tried to get State
Department permission his wife State
Department to meet with Russian nuclear
officials during the time of the Iranian
one deal and he eventually ended up
sitting down with Vladimir Putin himself
and as the author Peter Schweitzer
writes about in his best-selling book
Clinton cash the Clinton Foundation got
a hundred and forty five million dollars
in kickbacks from people that directly
benefitted from that deal we have
incontrovertible evidence that Putin and
his spies and his thugs were actually
successful because he eventually got 20%
of America's uranium the foundational
material for nuclear weapons
this is beyond insanity and inexcusable
Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton the Obama
administration allowed your national
security to be compromised in what is an
unprecedented way and few in the media
will touch this story major crimes were
committed they knew about it they did
nothing before the deal now here's a
simple question we have to ask it why on
earth would President Obama or Hillary
or Eric Holder ever sign off on giving
Russia a known enemy Putin a bad actor
20% control of our uranium what did
America get what did Obama get from this
uranium one deal it never made sense now
we also have incontrovertible evidence
that the Clinton campaign in the DNC
they paid fusion gps over nine million
dollars although nobody knows anything
and they hired a former British
intelligence
agent who then used current and former
Russian government sources to produce
this phony fake salacious news dossier
that was full of lies disinformation and
propaganda against Donald Trump
in other words Clinton and the DNC
funded the money to spread Russian lies
and influence the election they did it
all because it is the very thing they're
now accusing president Trump and his
campaign of doing they did it themselves
and we just found out this weekend this
new report from the Federals the
headline Obama's campaign paid nine
hundred and seventy two thousand dollars
to the law firm that secretly paid you
GPS and 2016 well the same firm that the
Clinton campaign the DNC used to pay
fusion GPS to create the fake news
propaganda anti-trump dossier that they
then regurgitated all over TV now we
also have robert muller and his band of
big democratic donors that work for him
now supposedly investigating trump
russia collusion and as I predicted
right here on the show there is still no
evidence that's ever happened none now
former current and top Democrats have
all said the same thing
smoke but no fire smoke but no fire
what's this have you seen anything that
suggests any collusion between the
Russians and the Trump campaign well
there's an awful lot of smoke there
let's put it that way people that might
have said they were involved to what
extent they were involved to what extent
the president might have known about
these people or whatever there's nothing
there from that standpoint that we have
seen directly linking our president to
any of that the last time we spoke
senator I asked you if you had actually
seen evidence of collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russians and you
said to me and I'm quoting you know you
said not at this time has anything
changed since we spoke last well not you
know it hasn't I know we need to go sim
but just to be clear we haven't there
has been no actual evidence yet no it
has not at the time I left I did not
have seen any smoking gun certitude
evidence of collusion is there any
evidence of collusion that you have seen
yet is there listen there is a lot of
smoke
we have no smoking gun at this point no
smoking gun tonight still no smoking gun
and you're lying media in this country
would have all of you believe the
indictment of Paul Manafort
and as associate Rick Gates has
everything to do with Trump Russia
collusion it has nothing to do with it
here's the truth nothing now none of
that is related to President Trump none
of it zero is related to his campaign
and the vast majority of these
allegations all happen before Paul
Manafort ever worked for the Trump
campaign and also tonight the issue of
robert muller attempting to change the
narrative
to distract from the real Russia
collusion and massive cover-ups don't
think this is a coincidence last week
right here on this program we had
stunning revelation after revelation day
after day about Hillary Clinton uranium
won the fake news dossier and that
special counsel Muller is clearly
complicit in the uranium 1 scandal
remember he was the FBI director the FBI
informant had all the effort evidence of
bribes and kickbacks and money
laundering and he did nothing so now
they need to change the narrative after
a very bad week and distract the country
from their evidence and their
involvement impossible collusion and by
the way mr. Muller who leaked the
indictments to fake News CNN was it you
now I can confirm exclusively here
tonight on Hannity Friday night all day
Saturday Madame ports team did not know
this was coming so somebody disclose
this information that is a crime mr.
Muller you should know this and by the
way anybody from the grand jury it's a
simple crime who did it
did anyone mr. Muller in your office do
it now while liberals in the media are
hysterical absolutely beside themselves
with giddiness thinking this is the big
smoking gun about Paul Manafort there's
another major shoe dropping in these
major Democratic scandals now we first
reported on Tony Podesta over a week ago
on October the 24th he's the brother of
Clinton's former campaign manager John
Podesta and according to Politico Tony
Podesta is now stepping down from his
lobbying group because he is being
investigated by the special counsel and
as we have now been reporting the probe
into Tony Podesta and his lobbying group
came about after Muller started looking
at a matter for its finances NBC News
even pointed out the Podesta's group
work with man afford on a public
relations campaign called European
center for a modern Ukraine and NBC News
even as that Muller could be looking
into whether Podesta and his company
violated what's known as fara the
foreign agents Registration Act and
Politico was reporting that both Tony
and yet John Podesta Hillary's campaign
manager and even Sid Vicious Blumenthal
they were all conveniently together this
weekend at Hillary Clinton's birthday
party in Washington hmm wonder what
everybody talked about and after new
revelations at the Clinton campaign and
the DNC paid almost ten million dollars
to help spread Russia anti Trump lies in
propaganda well now even senator Susan
Collins is saying that John Podesta and
disgraced former DNC chair debbie
Wasserman Schultz they need to retest
off' i before congress about the phony
clinton russian lying dossier that was
meant to influence the american people
on the eve of an election watch this
they absolutely need to be recalled it's
difficult to imagine that a campaign
chairman that the head of the DNC would
not know of an expenditure of this
magnitude and significance but perhaps
there's something more going on here but
certainly it's worth additional
questioning of those two witnesses that
you need to know there is no chance that
over ten million dollars goes out the
door to pay for this lying dossier you
and nobody knows about if you listen to
the Clinton people the DNC people I
don't know I don't know I don't know
nobody knows ten million dollars out the
door and guess what they're all lying
because they all use the same attorney
and the same law firm take a look how
congressman and former prosecutor trey
Gowdy is now properly interpreting well
Clinton in the DNC and now Obama did in
paying for this dossier this is
interesting
I'm not an election law expert Chris but
the good news is you don't have to be to
understand the absurdity of believing
that you can launder all of your
campaign money by just hiring a law firm
I mean imagine if you and I were running
for Congress and we just hired a law
firm and said hey you go do all the oppo
you go buy all the television you go buy
all the bumper stickers you go hire all
the experts and we're gonna launder all
of this through a law firm I can't think
of anything that defeats the purpose of
transparency laws more than that this is
not hyperbole I am NOT overstating the
case we are at a major crisis point in
America tonight do we have equal justice
under the law in this country today if
you or I if anybody in this room with me
now
or watching TV with you if we ever did
anything close to what the clintons the
DNC and others did we would be rotting
in a jail cell tonight hoping our
friends would send us a cake that had a
file the only difference between Trump
Russia collusion is that we have the
evidence and after a year of black
helicopter conspiracy theories they have
none and just like we have the evidence
when it comes to Clinton and her email
server scandal why hasn't she been
charged Fox News legal analyst Gregg
Jarrett who'll join us tonight has
helped us put together a list of all the
laws broken in all of these scandals
take a look at the side of your screen
these are the laws that were potentially
broken all by the Clinton campaign and
the DNC in the fake news dossier scandal
there of course they use Russian sources
bought and paid for by Hillary the DNC
and Obama to smear Trump and influence
the election with Russian lies then
there's the massive uranium 1 scandal
that Congress rightly is now
investigating we do need a special
prosecutor finally you have look right
there federal statutes involving crimes
like bribery and mail fraud and and wire
fraud and racketeering and as we've been
saying all of this is beyond serious it
compromised our national security and
people should be put behind bars there's
also the Clinton email server scandal I
haven't forgotten truth matters the law
matters equal justice matters remember
she had secret top secret special access
program classified information on a
server stored in the bathroom of a
mom-and-pop shop her team also deleted
over 33,000 subpoenaed emails using
bleach bitten acid wash smashing
blackberries and other devices with a
hammer
removing the SIM cards before giving the
mobile devices to the FBI
that's called obstruction of justice
that's a felony and just to recap since
it's so vitally important probably the
biggest scandal of all is Bill and
Hillary Clinton selling out America's
national security to Putin and the
Russians and guess what the FBI had the
information before they made the deal
and the FBI directors name at that time
was Rob
Muller and Eric Holder was the Attorney
General at the time who oversaw the FBI
they had to know and yet a year later
when even though they had evidence of
bribery and collusion and money
laundering and all these crimes they
ignored the evidence and Eric Holder and
Clinton signed off on the single beyond
the Iranian deal dumbest national
security decision ever
rod Rosenstein he oversaw the
investigation remember he's the guy that
appointed Muller on a local level while
he was serving as a US Attorney for
Maryland he appointed Muller to be the
special counsel here this is beyond
incestuous what about investigating
their roles in Russia Hillary Clinton's
State Department Eric Holder signed off
on the deal a year later knowing that
Putin's what his intentions were to
corner the uranium market Bill Clinton
makes a fortune doubles of speaking fees
paid with a check from a bank that has a
financial interest in uranium one he
tried to get his wife meetings with
Russian nuclear officials for him but he
met with Putin instead that was in 2009
then in 2010 Putin gets everything he
wants in spite of all the evidence of
his spies his agents committing crimes
in this country and as we mentioned
earlier between fusion GPS between
uranium one we have evidence of real
Russian collusion America tonight is at
a crisis point will we have equal
justice under the law will America just
be a Banana Republic corrupt at its core
that is what is at stake tonight and
that is what the corrupt media will
never tell you because the media is part
of the corruption that is the sewer that
is the swamp that is Washington DC so
tonight America has a choice we can have
equal justice for everyone or we can
live in a country where if you have the
right politics you stand for the right
left-wing positions you can sell out
your country and you can get away with
it guess what this program is dedicated
to the truth we will get to the bottom
of all of this